[Music]
are you driving a car that currently has
a recall in today's eight on your side
we break down how many dangerous cards
are on the roads in our state and what
steps you can take right now to find out
if yours is one of them
this month BMW issued a do not drive
recall for 90 000 older vehicles for
airbags that could explode Jeep recalled
220 000 Cherokee SUVs for a fire risk
with a park outside order these recalls
are serious as Carfax editor-in-chief
Patrick Olsen here's why do not drive
means the automaker and the federal
government is telling you your car
should be parked the automate will send
a tow truck take it to the dealership
get it fixed and bring it back to you
park outside cars are ones that have
recall that say there is such a fire
risk with this vehicle that not only
should you not park it in your garage
ideally you shouldn't park it next to
your garage and if you can't park it
away from any structure but even with
these risks Nationwide there are more
than 2.5 million vehicles that currently
have one of these recalls California and
Texas have the most at a quarter million
each and there are 22 000 of these
recalls for our state there could be
terrible consequences for consumers who
don't get these fixed Olson says the
federal government is required by law to
send notification of these recalls by
first class mail but he believes some
people who see them just ignore them
others think it's a car warranty
marketing scam and then there's this
reason frankly there's a small but
significant percentage I think of owners
who need their car for their livelihood
and who are unwilling or unable to get
off the car even for the short couple of
hours it might take to get that car
fixed for free there are two things you
can do right now to find out if your
vehicle is one of these under recall go
to carfax.com forward slash recall put
in your VIN or license plate it'll tell
you for free if you have an unfixed
recall
the other thing you can do is download
the Carfax Car Care app if you register
your car at no cost to you it will alert
you if a recall is issued and you'll get
notified years from now on a recall that
occurs